yes when you met Meryl embarrassed no
you did not because Oh scared of me no
she's not she's not look at how into
eyes are okay like I want to wear her
skin oh my god your eyes we're burying
today didn't expect it to happen yell
I'm not around actors ever until now
this show but like I'm never at each
other our musicians it was it's actually
a thing of beauty because I was walking
this way and I didn't realize that Mara
was over here how I don't even know but
you were here and not your eyes were
saucers and I was like oh my god it's
like and for a minute I thought you were
like eyes were saucers for me I was like
[Laughter]
[Applause]
you turn to me you're like I just met
Muriel I told you remember I blacked out
and then I proceeded to black out I mean
both laugh like now I was like I mean
poor other girls it would they were just
staying there and I was like in Merrell
yeah I actually have met her in black
heaven is what she told me I was
annoying because she thought it would
play that I was in and she meant it is
it a compliment but the first words ever
from Meryl Streep oh my god oh annoying
good job she saw me in a play that's
what I'm after a few months of therapy
that's what I thought I will not stop
talking until you subscribe to my
youtube channel that's right and I could
talk a lot seriously not gonna stop yep
still here not going anywhere I see you
don't walk away from this